[Music]
new here at new Nevada Arizona and
California say there's an agreement to
cut Colorado River water use but
short on details here the agreement
would cut water use by 20 percent by the
end of 2024. it doesn't say though how
much each state will cut the
announcement keeps the federal
government from imposing cuts on the
states for now a larger long-term deal
for the entire River still needs to be
reached and the goal is to of course
keep our Lake Mead from shrinking too
much Nevada isn't likely to see much of
these Cuts as we were already the
smallest and most efficient water user
California the largest water user and
they're going to have to cut the most